Allora, bene, buonasera a tutti.
Questa sera siamo al terzo appuntamento, insomma, con questo tentativo di far conoscenza con gli uomini del Medioevo.
Mentre lo dico, mi rendo conto che non ho parlato di donne. C'è un grosso problema in questo.
La stragrande maggioranza delle persone che nel Medioevo hanno scritto erano uomini.
C'erano anche delle donne e avrei potuto pensarci prima, forse.
Per l'anno prossimo le prometto, se vogliono qui.
Però sono stato pigro, perché quando noi pensiamo al Medioevo lo pensiamo sempre un po' fatto così, per categorie, no?
Appunto, come ho fatto io qui? Il frate, il cavaliere, il mercante, il contadino, con le donne più difficile.
Le donne sono, come dire, hanno un'opposizione sociale, ma hanno anche qualcosa di più.
Sono più difficili da incasellare, almeno in quell'epoca lì.
Ripeto, magari ne riparleremo.
Questa sera è il cavaliere.
Il cavaliere di cui parliamo è un francese, si chiama Jean de Joanville.
È un cavaliere del 200, contemporaneo di quel salimbene, di quel fras salimbene, di cui abbiamo parlato l'altro ieri.
A dir le verità è qualcosa di più di un cavaliere. È un capo di cavaliere, è un gran signore.
La maggior parte dei cavalieri sono dei gentiluomini che vivono bene, che hanno terra, servitori, cavalli, ma sono al servizio di qualcuno.
Sono al servizio di un castellano, di un gran signore.
Il quale è un cavaliere anche lui?
Ma, insomma, è un livello un po' superiore.
Joanville è un uomo così, è uno che possiede diversi castelli,
quindi possiede una signoria dove lui è il signore, dove lui è l'autorità pubblica.
Lui mantiene l'ordine, riscuote le imposte, amministra la giustizia.
E per di più è anche un grande funzionario del re.
Joanville ha servito per anni il re di Francia come siniscalco di champagne,
cioè amministratore rappresentante del re nella regione di champagne.
E con tutto questo è un cavaliere.
Essere un cavaliere vuol dire essere stati educati in un certo modo, condividere certi valori,
che magari sono anche quelli che raccontano i romanzi, i romanzi medievali che tutti abbiamo presenti
e che anche loro leggevano, dove si dice che il cavaliere deve proteggere le vedo,
vegli orfani, essere umile e così via.
Poi in realtà i veri valori dei cavaliere sono piuttosto altri.
I valori veri che Joanville condivide con i suoi vassalli sono il valore in guerra,
il coraggio fisico dimostrato in battaglia quando si rischia la pelle,
il cameratismo fra compagni d'arme, l'onore.
Detto questo, Joanville è famoso fra noi storici e io posso parlarvi di lui stasera
perché ha fatto una cosa che per i cavaliere era piuttosto insolita, ha scritto un libro.
Ha scritto un libro per un motivo preciso.
Lui ha servito come vi dicevo a lungo il re di Francia e il re che lui ha maggiormente servito
è stato Luigi IX, il santo, il grande re di Francia del 200 che è stato protagonista
di due crociate e nella seconda c'è poi morto.
Joanville lo ha accompagnato nella prima crociata,
una spedizione che è partita nel 1248 e è tornata, i pochi che sono tornati,
sei anni dopo.
Poi alla seconda crociata del re Joanville non c'è più andato,
come molti superstiti della prima hanno preferito non andarci.
Il re c'è andato e c'è morto nel 70.
Joanville è sopravvissuto al suo re per tanti anni.
Quando era già vecchio, siamo già all'inizio del 300,
negli stessi anni in cui Dino Compagni che vi ho raccontato ieri viveva la politica fiorentina,
in quegli stessi anni, nel suo castello di Joanville,
lui si rende conto che uno dei pochi rimasti che si ricordano il re santo.
Nel frattempo Luigi IX è stato fatto santo davvero, l'hanno canonizzato,
ormai è ufficialmente un santo.
E allora a Joanville viene voglia di scrivere,
e qualcuno gli chiede di scrivere,
e lui scrive, scrive questo straordinario libro
che dovrebbe essere una vita di Luigi IX
e che in realtà sono le memorie di Jean de Joanville,
di questo gran signore francese del suo tempo,
dove si racconta soprattutto questa epopea della crociata.
E dunque, e dunque non è soltanto un cavaliere,
ma è un cavaliere crociato quello che abbiamo di fronte stasera.
E credo di non stupire nessuno se dico che nella visione del mondo
di questo cavaliere crociato,
che per di più sta ricordando i tempi della crociata proprio,
ebbene in questa visione del mondo la religione ha un posto centrale.
Qui non rimane dell'uso chi ha in mente, diciamo,
un medioevo dominato dalla religione.
È vero che per molti, quasi tutti,
la religione era comunque una dimensione vissuta
con un'intensità che oggi, insomma, pochi si immaginano.
Non parlo solo di Luigi IX, che infatti è stato fatto santo.
Io pensavo prima di farvi l'elenco di tutte le messe e gli uffici divini
che Luigi IX sentiva ogni giorno della sua vita.
Poi ho pensato che perdevamo troppo tempo a fare questo questo lungo elenco,
ma il re sentiva diverse messe e parecchi uffici divini cantati e no ogni giorno.
Era un santo, Jeanville, che è un cavaliere qualunque,
signore qualunque, una messa al giorno però la sente.
La giornata di un cristiano e la giornata di un cavaliere comincia con la messa.
E la religione è sempre presente.
C'è una familiarità spontanea con le cose della religione
che è caratteristica di questa gente.
Entravano i cani in chiesa nel medioevo,
quindi noi qui non ci facciamo certo spaventare.
Racconto un aneddoto che rende l'idea di come loro ragionavano.
Stanno tornando dalla crociata, dopo essertati fuori sei anni,
e aver visto morire la maggior parte dei loro amici.
Tornando dalla crociata che è stata in Egitto e loro tornano per mare,
a un certo punto fanno scalo alla Ampedusa,
come capita quelli che partono dall'Egitto e vanno per mare, naturalmente.
Fanno scalo alla Ampedusa che trovano deserta, non ci vive nessuno.
Però ci sono gli avanzi, anzi c'è ancora un remitaggio.
Loro capiscono subito che è un remitaggio.
Si vede che è una casetta isolata con il suo orto,
con il suo giardino dove ci sono dei fighi, delle viti, degli olivi,
e poi ha una cappella, un oratorio.
Quello che fa capire che è un remitaggio.
C'è un oratorio inviancato a calce con un crocifisso,
e non c'è nessuno.
Nella stanza accanto ci sono due scheletri.
Ci sono due morti che sono stati ricomposti dopo la morte e lasciati lì,
e sono evidentemente gli remiti che hanno vissuto in quel luogo.
Loro sono tutti commossi, poi hanno fatto acqua,
se ne tornano alle galere per ripartire,
al momento di ripartire si accorgono che manca un marinaio.
Manca un marinaio, aspetta, aspetta, non torna,
finalmente quelli che lo conoscono dicono,
ma secondo noi si è fermato qua per fare le remita a lui.
C'è stata questa occasione, quello che fino a un momento fa,
chissà cos'altro pensava di fare della sua vita,
e invece è rimasto così colpito dalla scoperta di questo remitaggio deserto
abbandonato da decidere di fare le remita.
E questa cosa sembra naturale a tutti.
Tutti dicono è certo, evidentemente è così.
Gli lasciano delle casse di biscotto sulla spiaggia,
in modo che possa nutrirsi per un po',
e poi arriverà qualche altra nave e continuerà a mantenere le remita
e ripartono, e per loro è una vicenda normale.
Così come è normale che avvengano i miracoli.
Poi sapete, i miracoli se uno ci crede avvengono,
allora ci credevano praticamente tutti e quindi avvenivano.
Era facile essere sicuri di aver assistito a un miracolo.
E aver assistito a un miracolo era una cosa importante
che ti restava impresa, che ti portavi dietro,
specialmente durante una crociata catastrofica come quella di San Luigi,
di miracoli ce ne vogliono tanti per aiutarli a tornare a casa ai superstiti.
Juvenville ha assistito personalmente a un miracolo,
sempre durante il viaggio, di ritorno,
a un certo punto dalla nave davanti alla sua,
uno si era ampicato da qualche parte per fare qualche lavoro sulla nave,
e caduto in acqua.
Juvenville dice, noi dalla nave dietro vedevamo questa cosa in acqua,
ma era immobile, tanto che abbiamo pensato che fosse un pacco,
un mobile, qualcosa che era caduto lì, un oggetto che era caduto in mare.
Comunque mettiamo in mare la barca per andarlo a recuperare,
si scopre che è un uomo marinaio,
e vivo e vegeto sta benissimo.
E gli chiediamo, ma perché non nuotavi, non cercavi di agitarti, di chiamare?
E il marinaio dice Juvenville, che l'ha sentito con le sue orecchie,
ha detto, ma non c'era niche bisogno,
perché quando mi sono sentito che cadevo in mare,
ho invocato la vergine di vover,
e la vergine di vover mi è apparsa e mi ha tenuto su,
e io mi sono sentito che mi teneva su, e mi teneva a galla,
perciò stavo tranquillo.
E Juvenville ha assistito con i suoi occhi a un miracolo.
Lo racconta così ampassant, potrebbe essere finita qua.
Invece, nella frase dopo, dice,
e io l'ho fatto dipingere nella cappella di Juvenville,
e nelle vetrate della Chiesa di Blackhur,
che è l'altro villaggio che gli appartiene.
Questo vuol dire che anche se lui adesso non ci insiste,
perché aveva sentito un miracolo, può capitare a tutti insomma,
però poi quando ti capita davvero a te,
è una cosa che te la senti dentro,
e lui che è il signore del villaggio, lo fa frescare nella Chiesa,
lo fa mettere nelle vetrate, e così via.
Ecco, questo è il mondo in cui loro vivono dal punto di vista religioso,
dove la religione è un grande collante che accomuna tutti,
ed è sentita con estrema, come dire, con grande fervore,
e grande semplicità anche.
Anche troppa semplicità certe volte.
Juvenville racconta un episodio con grande approvazione, devo dire.
E c'è stata una volta, mi hanno raccontato,
direcente, al Monastero di Cluny, sapete Cluny in Borgogna,
grande Monastero benedettino,
a Monastero di Cluny avevano organizzato
una grande disputa di Chierici e di Ebrei.
Le dispute erano una cosa,
forse l'ho già accennato parlando di frassa limbene,
le dispute intellettuali pubbliche
erano una cosa che piaceva molto ai Chierici,
agli uomini di Chiesa del Medioevo.
Gli piaceva questa occasione di dimostrare quanto erano bravi,
affrontando degli avversari, discutendo con loro.
I loro fratelli che non si erano fatti preti,
facevano i tornei e ogni giorno dimostravano
di essere i più bravi, sconfiggendo un avversario.
Anche gli ecclesiastici piaceva farlo.
Dunque al Monastero di Cluny si organizza una disputa teologica
fra dei Chierici e dei Rabbini.
E c'era lì, dice Juvenville, mi hanno raccontato,
un vecchio cavaliere che viveva lì al Monastero,
l'abate lo manteneva per carità.
Capitava spesso che un cavaliere che aveva passato la vita
a combattere, a menare le mani, in vecchiaia,
intanto non ne poteva più fisicamente,
e magari ne aveva anche abbastanza di quella vita,
spesso in vecchiaia andavano a vivere in Monastero.
Chi aveva qualcosa regalava i suoi beni al Monastero,
chi non aveva niente poteva anche essere accolto per carità,
e passavano gli ultimi anni di vita in Monastero.
Allora, dice Juvenville, mi hanno raccontato
che nel momento in cui doveva cominciare la disputa,
questo cavaliere si è fatto avanti
e ha chiesto di poter essere il primo a disputare col rabbino.
L'abate non è che fosse tanto contento,
però l'altro insisteva e ha dovuto dargli d'accordo.
Comincia tu.
Allora, il cavaliere ha appoggiato alla sua gruccia.
Molto cortesemente chiede al rabbino, maestro,
ma voi ci credete alla vergine Maria che ha partorito
nostro Signore Idio ed è rimasta vergine?
Allora, il rabbino dice Juvenville,
gli rispose che loro non ci credevano neanche un po',
e il cavaliere rispose, fate molto male,
e alzò la gruccia e assistò una gran botta
sulla testa del rabbino.
E gli ebrei si portarono via il rabbino
e la disputa finì lì.
E Juvenville ne ha parlato col santore Luigi di questa cosa,
e tutte e due si sono trovati d'accordo che il cavaliere
ha fatto benissimo, perché disputare con i miscredenti,
insomma, è già pericoloso, però lo possono fare i dotti
sapienti che riescono a tenergli testa,
perché se va male, se vincono gli ebrei
nella disputa pubblica, ecco,
ci può essere anche qualcuno che,
qualche bravo cristiano che ha le idee confusa a quel punto,
quindi bisogna stare attenti.
I laici in queste cose non si devono mescolare.
I laici gli dice il santore,
quando sentono parlar male della fede cristiana,
devono tirar fuori la spada.
Dunque, questa fede così spontanea,
così irruente, anche così violenta, così intensa, certe volte.
Ecco, non vi stupirete, se vi dico che anche una fede
è molto attaccata alle forme, molto formalistica,
perché appunto una fede ingenuo vuole anche dire
che, insomma, io ci tengo a far le cose giuste,
a rispettare il digiuno del venerdì,
il digiuno dell'aquaresima,
e se queste cose non le rispetto,
mi sento veramente male,
sono cose che,
nel cristianesimo di oggi hanno perso importanza,
e invece allora,
il cristiano si senteva potentemente obbligato
a rispettare tutte queste cose.
È successo proprio la sua invildi,
sperimentarlo di persona.
Siamo durante la crociata.
Anzi, verso la fine della crociata,
che è già finita malissimo,
i sturchi hanno vinto,
hanno massacrato mezzo esercito crociato,
hanno catturato tutti gli altri.
Sono scene che Giovanville,
tra l'altro, descrive con una potenza straordinaria.
Ecco questi momenti di sfacelo, di fuga, di caos,
questi che si arrendono,
e arrendersi è un azzardo,
perché non sai nelle mani di chi finisci,
e i turchi, i saraceni,
è difficile prevedere cosa faranno.
Ci sono quelli che, quando vedono dei prigionieri,
un po' malandati, malati, etc.,
una botta in testa e giù in mare,
invece, ci sono quelli che trattano molto cortesemente
i prigionieri.
Poi, comunque, il re e i Grandsignori
vengono sempre trattati molto cortesemente.
Quello va da sé,
anche perché pagheranno un grosso riscatto
per essere liberati,
ma poi, comunque, i re e i Grandsignori
cristiani o musulmani si capiscono,
fanno parte dello stesso mondo,
hanno tanti argomenti in comune, come vedremo subito.
Dunque, le cose sono già più o meno finite.
Giovanville è prigioniero
ed è a pranzo con un emiro che l'ha invitato a pranzo.
L'emiro, l'hambitato a pranzo,
stanno chiacchierando con l'interprete, si capisce specia.
Stanno chiacchierando, allegrammente,
dei respectivi alberigeniologici
e di conoscenze comuni.
Perché l'emiro è molto interessato
alle Imperatore Federico II,
viene fuori che Giovanville è parente
dell'Emperatore Federico II,
sono lì che confrontano le conoscenze
e gli antenati e mangiano.
Certo punto, capita un altro crociato
prigioniero, un borghese francese,
dice Giovanville.
E mi dice,
ma Messere, ma che cosa fate?
Mi dice, ma perché scusa, cosa sto facendo?
Ma per l'amor di Dio Messere
state mangiando carne di venerdì.
Giovanville salta in piedi,
allontana la scodella,
ho ripilato
perché, voi capita,
nel caos, la battaglia, la cattura,
tutto si era scordato che giorno era.
Era venerdì e stava mangiando carne.
L'emiro che assista a questa scena
gli fa chiedere dall'interprete
cosa è successo.
Giovanville lo spiega
e il musulmano gli dice, ma sta tranquillo
che Dio non può avercela con te,
non l'hai mica fatto apposta.
Giovanville però ci sta male.
Ci sta male di aver fatto questa cosa
appena può va a consultare il legato
papale presso l'esercito crociato.
Quindi un alto prelato
gli racconta tutto.
L'alto prelato gli dice la stessa cosa
che gli ha detto il musulmano.
Cioè Dio non può avercela con te,
non può non preoccuparti.
Giovanville non ci crede.
Si sente addosso questa cosa
e dice ho cominciato a digiunare a pane e acqua
tutti i venerdì
per liberarmi, per purificarmi
da questa cosa che avevo fatto.
Quindi le forme sono importanti.
Le forme sono importanti,
non bisogna trasgredirle
ed è una religiosità che pure essendo
lo abbiamo visto intensissima e spontanea
è anche attaccatissima
al rispetto delle regole formali.
L'uncia per esempio.
È un mondo curioso questo
perché tutti hanno continuamente
in bocca Dio e il diavolo.
Tutti continuamente, tutti giurano,
quando si deve dire qualcosa,
tutti dicono per Dio, per nome di Dio,
per la testa di Dio, per le piaghe di Dio,
ognuno ha il suo modo di giurare.
Giovanville spesso lo nota,
ci sono dei grandi signori che hanno un modo particolare di giurare,
c'è uno che giura per la cuffia di Dio.
Continuamente.
E dall'altra dice, tutti hanno sempre in bocca il diavolo,
questa dice Giovanville è una cosa brutta,
è una delle tragedie del nostro rebelo regno di Francia.
Il santo re Luigi,
lui non menzionava mai ne Dio nel diavolo,
non l'ho mai sentito dir queste cose.
Invece, noi lo facciamo
e menzionare Dio in questo modo
in realtà non è la cosa più grave,
è grave menzionare il diavolo.
Infatti Giovanville dice, io a casa mia
ho stabilito una regola,
chiunque gli scappa di bocca di menzionare il diavolo,
o paga pegno o fa penitenza,
e fra i miei servi
è praticamente sparita questa brutta abitudine.
Menzionare Dio invece va bene,
uno per rafforzare le sue affermazioni
chiama Dio a testimone, anche lui l'ha fatto
e però ci si mette nei guai certe volte.
Racconta Giovanville
sempre durante la crociata,
come il grosso delle cose che vi racconto stasera.
I crociati si stavano spostando,
spostavano l'accampamento,
ogni sera mettevano le tende in un posto nuovo.
Una sera dice, è venuto uno dei miei cavalieri,
quello che aveva scelto il posto per la tenda,
quella sera,
e mi dice Sire,
si diceva Sire ai signori,
anche non soltanto i re,
in francese antico.
Sire, stasera
vi ho alloggiato meglio di ieri sera,
eh?
Il cavaliere che aveva scelto il posto per la tenda
ieri sera sente questo,
salta su,
lo prende per i capelli e gli fa,
come osi parlare di qualcosa che faccio io?
Ora questa è una grandissima scortesia,
davanti al Signore a capigliarsi
tra cavaliere in questo modo,
è il massimo della villania
della maleducazione.
Gioenville non ci vede più e dice
così come Dio mi aiuti
tu non entrerai mai più in casa mia, ti licenzio.
Non sarai mai più uno dei miei cavalieri.
Questo se ne va piangendo,
poi torna lo implora
di perdonarlo,
fa venire gli amici che gli dicono
ma su per una cosa così,
e Gioenville dice, beh, io per me
però ho giurato,
ho detto così come Dio mi aiuti
tu non entrerai più in casa mia.
Adesso non posso mica
farti rientrare come se niente fosse.
Se il legato papale
mi scioglie dal mio giuramento,
io sono contentissimo di riprenderti.
Vanno dal legato papale
gli spiegano la cosa e il legato papale
dice, mi dispiace,
questo è un giuramento valido,
c'erano dei motivi, io non lo posso
mica sciogliere così come niente fosse,
non si può, e dice Gioenville
così ho imparato, bisogna stare attenti a quel che si dice.
Perché non l'ha più ripreso
il suo cavaliere dopo questa vicenda.
Un altro aspetto che colpisce
molto di questa religiosità
così come l'esprime Gioenville, ma certamente
è condiviso da tanti
è un altro aspetto di concretezza.
Dicevo prima che i miracoli avvengono.
Dicevo prima che si chiama
continuamente Dio a testimone
di quello che succede. C'è qualcosa di più,
ci si aspetta continuamente di essere
aiutati da Dio, dalla vergine,
dai santi. Ci si aspetta
continuamente che mentre uno è
traverso un guai, una difficoltà
invocando Dio,
Dio ti aiuta, e quando sei
in pericolo e rischi la pelle in battaglia
invochi Dio e Dio ti aiuta
e per questo che noi serviamo Dio,
dice Gioenville.
Durante la crociata
gli hanno spiegato che molti musulmani,
i Bedouini dice lui in particolare,
hanno una credenza molto strana,
hanno la credenza che l'uomo
porta scritte in fronte la sua morte
e che quindi può morire
soltanto nel giorno stabilito.
Voi lo sapete, si usa a dire
questa cosa del fatalismo musulmano
per cui ogni uomo
ha già il giorno prestabilito
della sua morte.
E Gioenville trova che questa è un'idea assurda
perché se uno ha già il giorno stabilito
della sua morte, è come dire
che Dio non ti può aiutare per cambiare le cose,
che Dio non ti può aiutare
quando sei lì che rischi la pelle in battaglia
e lo invochi e non serve a niente invocarlo
perché tanto è già tutto deciso.
E Gioenville dice, no, questa è una cosa ridicola.
Se fosse davvero così
e questa è la cosa che mi ha colpito di più,
la cosa più interessante, la conclusione più interessante
che lui ricava da questa cosa,
dice se fosse davvero così
ma sarebbero scemi
quelli che servono Dio.
Se noi non credessimo che abbia
il potere di allungarci la vita
e di aiutarci nelle difficoltà,
quello che lo serviamo
e a lui sembra perfettamente ovvio.
C'è un contratto con Dio
e questa è
la logica.
Dopodiché
forse cominciate già a intravedere
quella che a me sembra una
una grossa contraddizione di questa religiosità
che da un lato
è così calda e così sincera
e però non esclude al fatto
l'attaccamento
all'interesse concreto
ai vantaggi concreti
all'aiuto che si spera di ottenere.
Certo
servire Dio
vuol dire fare delle rinunce
anche delle rinunce pesanti certe volte
e chi lo può sapere
meglio di Joan Wilke ha passato 6 anni alla crociata
quando lui racconta
la partenza per la crociata
lo dice in poche parole
son partito
il re Luigi quando è partito lo raccontavo
l'altro ieri sera ha attraversato metà
il suo regno a piedi vestito da pellegrino
col bastone e la bisaccia
Joan Wilke non ha fatto la stessa cosa
ma anche lui allontanandosi del suo castello
di Joan Wilke
ha fatto il giro delle chiese
dei d'intorni a piedi umilmente
col bastone da pellegrino
prima di allontanarsi definitivamente
e dice mentre facevo il giro
non mi sono mai
voltato indietro a guardare verso
Joan Wilke perché non volevo che
mi venisse addosso la pena
del bel castello che stavo lasciando
di mia moglie e dei miei figli
quindi
di rinuncia se ne fanno
dopo quella partenza lui sta via 6 anni
prima di rivedere la moglie e i figli
e il castello di Joan Wilke
e però
di rinuncia se ne fanno ma il buon senso
si tiene sempre presente
non si va alla crociata per il gusto di farsi ammazzare
anzi
si va alla crociata sperando alla fine di salvarla pelle
e tornare indietro
a tutti i rifanatici questi crociati
questi cavalieri crociati
e la cosa viene fuori con assoluta
evidenza proprio
nel momento in cui i crociati
vengono sbaragliati e
i turchi cominciano a catturarli
Joan Wilke in quel momento è su una nave
loro stavano cercando
di scampare a bordo di queste navi
però gli arrivano addosso le galere
dei saraceni circondano la sua galera
lui è su questa nave con i suoi cavalieri
con tutti i suoi domestici, tutta la sua gente
gli arrivano addosso i saraceni
si preparano a bordare la galera
e Joan Wilke dice
noi ci sanchiesti che facciamo adesso
e ci si hanno trovati tutti d'accordo
ci arrendiamo
non c'è assolutamente niente da fare
ma uno dei miei domestici
dice un cantiniere
alzato la mano ha detto
io non sono d'accordo con questa decisione
e tu che cosa consigli?
io dico di farci ammazzare tutti
così andremo dritti in paradiso
e questo è veramente quel medioevo
come noi infondo ce lo aspettiamo
è interessante che sia
non un nobile cavaliere
ma uno qualunque che ha questa idea
siamo qua, andiamo fino in fondo
siamo coerenti fino al martirio
questo è il medioevo che ci aspettiamo
salvo che soltanto lui che lo dice
Joan Wilke dà la questione
con una frasetta
ma noi non gli abbiamo mica dato retta
e infatti si arrendono
e la scampano in gran parte
buon senso
religiosità
impegni religiosi
mantenere la parola
non è facile essere coerenti
in questo campo
il buon Luigi
era un santo
anche perché lui la parola la manteniva sempre
perfino con i saraceni
che è una cosa che a Joan Wilke
colpiscia abbastanza
ma con quelli
e invece è successo la vista lui
dopo la prigionia
stanno pagando il riscatto
ci sono stati lunghi negoziati
con i saraceni che li hanno catturati
alla fine hanno stabilito una grossissima
200.000 lire tornesi
un enorme somma per liberare il re
e i grandi signori
e a questo punto sono venuti i soldi dalla Francia
sono arrivati
giorni e giorni per contarli
per consegnarli quando hanno quasi finito
uno dei cavalieri del re
Messer Philippe de Némure
arriva tutto allegro e dice
sì re, li abbiamo imbrogliati
gli abbiamo dato 10.000 lire di meno
e non se ne sono accorti
sono tutti contenti
il re non è contento per niente
è un santo
queste cose lui non le fa
è imbronciato
e dice ma
io ho dato la mia parola di pagare 200.000 lire
e paghiamo 200.000 lire
questo punto succede
alla seguente commedia
peste il piede
a Messer Philippe de Némure
perché stia zitto
e dice ma no si re scherzava
non è mica vero
imbrogliare i saraceni chi ci riesce
sanno tutti che i saraceni sono bravissimi a contare
e Messer Philippe de Némure
che ha mangiato la foglia dice sì è vero, è vero
scherzavo
ma il re non si fa bindolare
rimane di pessimo umor
dice se hai scherzato erano scherzo stupido
e io adesso vado a controllare
perché voglio essere sicuro che abbiamo pagato tutto
perché questo peso
non me lo porto dietro
ecco non era facilissimo
convivere con questo re
come vedete, io ho cominciato raccontando
di un cavaliere crociato che ha una profonda religiosità
però
un conto è avere una profonda religiosità
è un conto di dover vivere con un re santo
che le cose le spinge
le spinge all'estremo
oltretutto
quando Giovenville scrive da vecchio
è ormai ufficiale
il re è santo
è stato canonizzato
ma quando avvenivano queste cose
che erano giovani tutti e due
sì il re aveva già questa fama di essere santo
ma insomma capite la differenza
Giovenville lo ammirava molto
lo amava molto però lavorarci insieme non era facile
proprio per niente
le occasioni di scontro c'erano continuamente
per fortuna c'era di buono questo
che il re aveva il senso dell'humorismo
e stava allo scherzo
perché più di una volta Giovenville
si è lasciate scappare grosse
una volta è capitato che
nell'accampamento dei crociati
momento di tregua con i saraceni
tutti tranquilli arrivano dei pellegrini
dei cristiani d'Oriente
Armeni
che stanno andando in pellegrinaggio a Gerusalemme
col permesso dei saraceni
attraversano il campo crociato
e poi cominciano a informarsi
e vanno anche a chiedere a Giovenville
dicendo ma noi abbiamo saputo che qui nel campo
c'è il re santo
possiamo vedere il re santo
Giovenville sia che si fosse svegliato male
quel mattino sia che questa cosa
che il re era un santo non gli era ancora proprio ben
entrato in testa
va dal re sono amici
l'altro il re
lui è un suo collaboratore ma sono in rapporti molto stretti
va dal re lo trova
dice seduto sotto la sua tenda
sulla sabbia con neanche
un tappeto sotto
e gli dice sire
lì fuori c'è della gente che dice che vuole vedere il santo
ma io non ho mica voglia di baciare le vostre ossa
baciare le vostre ossa
è una cosa che un
un uomo del medioevo abbia capito subito cosa vuole dire
le ossa dei santi le reliquie
i santi normalmente non sono vivi
la grande maggioranza dei santi sono morti
e noi il rapporto che abbiamo con loro
è perché abbiamo le loro reliquie
che per la gente del medioevo
sono importantissime
e le reliquie sono venerate
baciate certo
però andare a dire al re
non è ancora ora di baciare le tue ossa
non è proprio un modo gentile di mettere la cosa
per fortuna il re si mette a ridere
un'altra volta
succede
che c'è una questione di soldi
e forse qui dovrei fare una parentesi
perché io sto parlando di cavalieri crociati
poi fra poco parleremo di valore guerriero
di cortesia
di ideali cavallereschi
finora stiamo parlando di fede religiosa
di crociate, di martirio
ecco i soldi sembrerebbe che non dovessero
entrarci niente in tutto questo
errore
i soldi c'entrano moltissimo
una crociata costa un sacco di soldi
ed è una grande impresa
che va pianificata e la primissima cosa
è trovare i soldi
poi quando ci sono i soldi si può cominciare a organizzare
l'esercito, assumere cavalieri, rovar gente
fabbricare le nà e così via
questo costa carissimo
i soldi c'entrano dappertutto
un gruppo di cavalieri che parte
per la crociata al seguito di un signore
nove volte su dieci
sono stati assunti
regolarmente con regolare contratto
e pagati
è vero che ci sarebbe il sistema feudale
ogni signore ha i suoi vassalli
che dovrebbero prestar servizio
ma quelle sono cose vecchie
nessuno più presta servizio gratis
ecco tanto meno a andar lontano
i vassalli stessi
se accompagnano i signori in un'impresa pericolosa
come la crociata vogliono essere pagati
poi se uno riesce a mettere insieme
un gruppetto fatto tutto
di suoi vassalli, di suoi parenti
allora bene
John Will a un certo punto lo dice
durante un combattimento una squadra di cavalieri
che ha combattuto particolarmente
bene e dice beh quelli lì
erano tutti i vassalli o parenti
del loro signore
però questo è un caso ormai eccezionale
di solito i cavalieri uno li ha assunti
e l'ilicenzia come John Will
ha licenziato quel tale scortese
che poi se ne è pentito
dunque devi pagarli
e John Will ci racconta dettagliatamente
quanti soldi guadagnava lui
dalle sue terre quando è partito per la crociata
quanto ha speso per assumere i suoi 10 cavalieri
dopodiché
siccome la crociata l'organizza il re
un gran signore come John Will
che ha i suoi 10 cavalieri
è già un'unità di una certa rilevanza
perché un cavaliere armato
con l'armatura, i suoi cavalli, i suoi domestici
a verne 10
è già una cosa
John Will va dal re
e il re a sua volta lo assume
quindi gli paga una certa somma
per essere accompagnato da lui
dai suoi cavalieri, i soldi c'entrano in tutto
chi usa la parentesi
c'è stata una grana a un certo punto
perché il periodo contratto tra John Will
e il re era finito
bisognava rifare il contratto
ed era un momento di difficoltà
il re era rimasto senza un soldo
John Will invece era abbastanza
ben messo a mezzi
perciò decide di fare lo splendido
come dicono i nostri ragazzi oggi
va dal re
gli dice sarebbe ora di rifare il contratto
io sono pronto a prestare il servizio con i miei cavalieri
e il re dice sono contentissimo
quanto volete
non chiedete troppo
perché siamo messi molto male
e John Will gli dice ma è sta
non si diceva ancora si re dicono
si re
a me mi va bene fare un patto facciamo questo accordo
invece di pagarmi
facciamo l'accordo che
per tutti questi sei mesi che rimango al vostro servizio
con i miei cavalieri
non vi arrabbierete mai con me
perché voi ogni volta che uno vi viene a chiedere
qualcosa vi arrabbiate
e io sono stanco di sentire il re che si arrabbia
con me facciamo questo patto
se mi promettete di non arrabbiarvi più per sei mesi
io presto servizio gratis
cioè li pago io i cavalieri
e anche stavolta il re si mette a ridere
e finisce bene per fortuna
anzi è felice il re di questo bel gesto
cavalleresco
che ha fatto il sirio di John Will
e va subito a raccontarlo a tutti
e qui John Will ha mostrato effettivamente che lui non è un mercante
lui è un nobile cavaliere
i soldi sa che contano contano parecchio
gli importa verne
li conta anche lui ma all'occasione
si fa il grande gesto
perché il nobile appunto non è un mercante
non sta sempre soltanto a calcolare
dunque si diceva che vivere al fianco di San Luigi
non è facilissimo
anche perché il santo
il santo stesso non si rende mica conto certe volte
che lui è un santo
e non può pretendere dagli altri le stesse cose
che fa lui
San Luigi è uno che la sua santità la dimostra continuamente
la gente sbalordita
a un certo punto
fuori dall'accampamento dei crociati
sono rimasti dei cadaveri di morti
dell'ultima battaglia
è passato qualche giorno
sono in Africa d'estate
nessuno a più voglia di
andarli a seppellire non ci va nessuno
un bel pomeriggio vedono il re che esce
dalla tenda e si rimbocca le maniche
e va lui personalmente a cominciare a seppellire
questi cadaveri
allora si vergognano tutti ma morire e
accorrono
in più di un'occasione
consigliano al re
di salvarsi
perché le cose stanno andando male
in questa crociata
e di tornare a casa
e il re dice ma abbiamo i mezzi
per riportare indietro tutti
in questo momento i mezzi per riportare
indietro tutti non ci sono ma quello che conte
più di tutti è il re
bisogna salvare il re
e Luigi risponde
io vedo qui intorno a questa gente
e tutti quanti amano la loro vita
quanto io amo la mia
e perciò io non me ne andrò
lasciandoli qua a perdizione
dove la cosa interessante non è soltanto
come dire
questo tratto che non tutti i re
dell'epoca avrebbero condiviso
di preoccuparsi di salvare anche la povera gente
ma è il fatto che il re la sua vita la ama
gli sembra ovvio dirlo
io l'amo è come la mia vita
però so che l'amano anche gli altri
dopodiché dicevo
viverci vicino non è facile e gli episodi
che racconta Giovanville sono tanti
da questo punto di vista
un bel momento ci sono lui e il re che chiacchierano
e al re viene in mente di fargli
di porgli una domanda
dice Sire di Giovanville
una domanda un quesito
ditemi un po preferireste
essere all'ebroso
o aver commesso un peccato mortale
e Giovanville
gli risponde immediatamente
ma io preferirei averne fatti 30
di peccati mortali
piuttosto che essere all'ebroso
e si prende una lavata di capo memorabile
un'altra volta
Giovedì Santo
il re lava
i piedi ai poveri
in memoria di quel che fece
nostro signore
e poi vada Giovanville e dice
sai una gran bella cosa questo fatto
dovreste farlo anche voi
perché non lavate anche voi i piedi ai poveri
il Giovedì Santo Giovanville
e Giovanville gli risponde ma per la fede che devo a Dio
i piedi di quei villani io non li lavo
e anche stavolta
che si rimane male naturalmente
ma appunto Giovanville è uno che le dice le cose
le dice quando gli vengono in mente non si preoccupa
e su questo
non laverò i piedi
di questi villani
possiamo forse
lasciar da parte la dimensione religiosa
che ci ha occupati anche fin troppo a lungo
fin ora ma dopo tutto questo è un crociato
e parlare dell'altra dimensione
assolutamente centrale
della vita e della mentalità
di questi cavalieri
cioè questa mentalità
aristocratica
per cui la società è divisa
e ci sono i gentiluomini, i nobili, i cavalieri
i signori
e loro
sono il meglio che c'è
e poi ci sono i villani
e sono tutti i villani gli altri, sono quelli che lavorano
sono tutti i villani
non soltanto i contadini che zappano nel campo
ma anche i mercanti, i finanzieri
quelli che hanno fatto magari anche i soldi
e ne hanno magari di soldi tanti
quindi più dei cavalieri cominci a questo fenomeno
è una cosa
ignobile perché i villani
si sa, sono gente ignobile
le uniche persone per bene sono i nobili
sono i gentiluomini e sono i cavalieri
questa è una cosa che è eradicata
profondissimamente proprio come un automatismo
nella testa di quelli
come Joanville
e gli episodi di questo genere
sono innumerevoli
si trova alla Corte del Rè
arriva
gli viene incontro il cappellano del Rè
Mastro Robert Sorbon
che sarà poi famoso
perché fonderà il Collegio della Sorbonna
in cui poi avrà sede l'Università di Parigi
Mastro Robert Sorbon
vede entrare a Corte
e Joanville gli va incontro
lo prende per la falda dell'abito
e lo attira fino dal Rè
e Joanville è piuttosto stupito cosa diavolo sta succedendo
cosa diavolo appunto perché mi tanto scappa
e allora
Mastro Robert Sorbon chiama il Rè
quindi, qui, mi lamento a del sirio di Joanville
che viene a Corte
vestito così di pelliccia e tessuti preziosi
quando il Rè
guardate un po' non è vestito così bene quanto voi
quella era ancora un'epoca
l'ho già detto altre volte relativamente semplice
relativamente modesta
il lusso non era ancora tale
neanche nelle corti Rè era vestito di tessuto normale
Joanville è vestito di pelliccia
si sente dire questa cosa
e reagisce Bandit reagisceenth con durezza estrema
cioè, agli dice Mastro Robert
quest'abito che io porto
me l'ha lasciato in eredità mio padre
e l'abito che può portare
chi viene da una famiglia come la mia
io sono vestito come era vestito mio padre
non si può dire la stessa cosa di voi
guardatevi un po'
anche voi siete vestito di tessuti preziosi
tutti sanno che vostro padre era un villano qualunque
ed è vero
Roberto Sorbonne uno dei tanti che attraverso la chiesa
fanno carriera venendo dal basso
c'è questa scena spiacevolissima
c'è questa scena spiacevolissima a corte
il re si intromette
difende Roberto Sorbonne
mette fine alla cosa
e poi però c'è una coda
perché poi più tardi arriva a prendere
Joanville e gli dice
stire di Joanville io mi devo scusare
perché ho difeso Mastro Robert
e non se lo meritava perché avevate ragione voi
però ho visto talmente confuso
talmente humiliato
che non me la son sentita di lasciarlo così in difficoltà
però avevate ragione voi
perché i nobili
vanno vestiti di pelliccia
perché così andavano vestiti il loro padre
e i loro nonni
e il villano rifatto il parvenu
che ha appena fatto i soldi
non deve permettersi di mettersi a loro livello
è una mentalità che durerà per secoli
detto fra parentesi
e si arriverà non dico alla rivoluzione francese
ma addirittura al pieno 800
perché comincia a tramontare nella nobiltà europea
questa idea di essere
intrinsecamente superiore
e che tutti gli altri
ci hanno gente che va al poco
eppure
Joanville lo sa
lo dicevo prima
comincia a esserci qualcuno di questi villani rifatti
che ha fatto talmente tanti soldi
che sono diventati persone importanti
comprano castelli
occupano posizioni importanti a corte
e questa è una cosa
difficile da accettare
non c'è niente di più divertente che vederli rimessi al loro posto
questi villani che hanno fatto carriera
alla corte del conte di champagne
racconta Joanville
c'era un borghese ricchissimo
aveva fatto un sacco di soldi
era un uomo importante
un giorno alla corte del conte di champagne
arriva un povero cavaliere
senza mezzi
che si rivolge al conte
supplicandolo di regalargli qualcosa
per poter fare la dotte alle sue figlie
è Erto de Nozhan
che è lì
gli dice Massire Cavaliere
cosa venite a chiedere soldi
cosa venite a chiedere un regalo al conte
il conte ha già regalato fin troppo
non ha più niente da regalare
e lo manda via in malo modo
il conte lì ha sentito tutto
interviene immediatamente
si rivolge al gramborghese
Erto de Nozhan
e gli dice signor villano come vi permettete di dire
che non ho più niente da regalare
lo afferra per l'abito
e lo sbatte tra le mani del cavaliere
dicendo te lo consegno
lasciarlo andare solo quando avrà pagato un riscatto
come si fa in guerra
che si catturano i prigionieri
i prigionieri vengono liberati
e questa storia di come
Erto de Nozhan è stato rimesso al suo posto
ovviamente fa il giro
delle corti di Francia
e i cavalieri si rallegrano
perché può succedere che un cavaliere povero
venga umiliato da un ricco borghese
o come dire, fa giustizia
può far giustizia in modo anche a sai più
drammatici perché su questo non si transigge
è fondamentale che le gerarchie
sociali vengano rispettate
a un certo punto
durante la crociata
un sergente del re
che sarebbe come dire
diciamo un poliziotto oggi sostanzialmente
un dipendente del re
armato
litiga con uno dei cavalieri di Joanville
e lo spintona
Joanville viene a sapere questa cosa
e fuori di sé
va dal re
esige giustizia
e la giustizia
verifica la consuetudine
prevede che in un caso del genere
se un villano si permette di mettere la mano addosso
a un cavaliere bisogna tagliargli la mano
e il re
non vorrebbe
però dice che non ci si può far niente
e la consuetudine non si applica mai
però se qui si pretende
questa è la consuetudine
e il sergente deve venire scalzo in camicia
a inginocchiarsi davanti al cavaliere
che aveva spintonato
e implorare il suo perdono
e allungare la mano e dire messer cavaliere
io imploro il vostro perdono, qui c'è la mia mano
se la volete la potete tagliare
dopodiché tutti dicono
no va bene d'accordo
perdoniamolo, su perdoniamolo, perdonamolo
perdonamolo, lo perdonano effettivamente
ma il principio
è stato stabilito una volta di più
ora come si giustifica
ai loro occhi, dico perché non si giustifica
se vogliamo, ma ai loro occhi
come si giustifica questa idea che i nobili
sono il sale della terra, che i cavalieri
sono il meglio che ci sia
e tutti gli altri non contano niente
fondamentalmente qui
il problema è che i nobili si sentono
e sono in gran parte
quelli che fanno la guerra
rischiano la pelle
gli altri lavorano, fanno i soldi
ma il mestiere del cavaliere
è rischiare la vita
il mestiere del cavaliere è rischiare la vita
per il suo signore, per i suoi compagni d'arme
per le altà, per la causa
per la croce
quando si va incrociata
il mestiere del cavaliere è un mestiere duro
noi non ce ne rendiamo conto oggi
provate a pensarci cosa vuol dire
saper stare a cavallo
con un'armatura di 40 kg addosso
e saper tirare un colpo di lancia
al tuo avversario e buttarlo giù da cavallo
e se invece lui beccatete
sbatte giù da cavallo
sopravvivere a tutto questo
ed essere pronto a ricominciare
è uno sport durissimo
l'addestramento dei cavaliere
uno sport estremo in cui si lascia la pelle facilmente
oltretutto
è uno sport che bisogna cominciare a praticare da bambini
un proverbio medievale dice
uno che ha 8 anni
non è ancora montato a cavallo
ormai è buono solo a fare il prete
se vuoi fare il cavaliere
e tener alto l'onore
tu o della tua famiglia e farti rispettare
e prestare servizio per il tuo signore, per il tuo re
devi cominciare da bambini
e andare avanti tutta la vita
bisogna allenarsi continuamente
e stare in guerra significa
stare lì ore, ore al caldo, al freddo
al gelo con l'armatura addosso
senza niente da bere, niente da mangiare
i nobili si raccontano queste cose
quindi, a dire il vero, uno va a vedere
negli eserciti ci sarebbero anche i fantascini
i domestici, i servitori, la gente a piedi
che spesso sono quelli che vengono ammazzati per primi
quando le cose vanno male
ma i nobili non li vedono neanche
vedono se stessi sui loro cavalli
con i loro elmi
giù in villa è una pagina straordinaria
quando descrive il re luigi che sbarca in Egitto
per primo dalla sua galera
a cavallo con la lancia in pugno
con l'elmo dorato
si butta in mare che ancora lontano
sguazzando nel mare sbarca
e da solo
e già pronto dove sono i turchi
andrebbe da solo a caricarli
se lo lasciassero andare
ecco questo orgoglio
del valore cavalleresco
questo orgoglio di essere quelli che rischiano
la vita continuamente per principio
per obbligo
è la cosa che i cavalieri sentono
giustifica tutti i loro privilegi
poi naturalmente ce n'esserebbero
anche altre di cosa che dovrebbero
giustificare i loro privilegi naturalmente
dovrebbero essere anche
i più beneducati
i più cortesi, i più raffinati
quelli che sanno tra
e in parte è vero perché loro danno importanza
queste cose
poi le scene che racconta giù in villa
ci fanno vedere che spesso la realtà non era quella
però
quando i cavalieri si comportano da villani
gli altri ci rimangono male
giù in villa a un certo punto racconta proprio una vicenda così
era stato ammazzato uno dei miei cavalieri
in combattimento
gli altri lo vegliavano
il cadavere sono andato lì
e li ho visti che ridevano
perché ridete
diciamo ah niente
stavamo pensando che adesso bisognerà far risposare
sua moglie
e giù in villa ci rimane malissimo
e gli dice ma come permettete il vostro camerata è lì
ancora caldo e voi siete lì che scherzate
su chi si sposerà sua moglie
vergogna
dopodiché dice
sono stati puniti
perché prima della fine della crociata erano morti tutti
e tutte le loro moglie
si sono risposate
dopodiché appunto
il comportamento con le donne
il comportamento
nelle camere delle donne come si dice certe volte
il saper stare
con le donne
le essere eleganti raffinati cortesi
è un'interistica che in questo ambiente sociale
è valorizzata
è importante
ancora una volta il re luigi si distingue
è diverso dagli altri
giù in villa nota
re luigi è uno che alle donne non ci pensa proprio
è sposato
ma dice giù in villa
una delle cose brutte di lui
e che con sua moglie e con i suoi figli praticamente
era come se fossero estranei
e questa è una cosa che colpisce
che non va bene rispetto ai valori
ai comportamenti dei cavalieri
poi in realtà se volessimo
vogliamo 5 minuti le abbiamo ancora
il re luigi
c'erano dei motivi per questo
e il re luigi è un altro personaggio
che se uno dovesse applicarci un po' di psicanalisi
verrebbero fuori delle cose interessanti
perché il re
ha perso il padre molto giovane
ed è rimasto per anni
sotto la tutela della madre
la regina bianca di castiglia
tremenda donna di potere
che per anni ha governato il regno
finché lui gira bambino
e poi quando lui è diventato grande
l'ha preso in pugno lui il regno
ma bianca di castiglia la mamma era sempre presente
e controllava tutto
e il re si è dovuto sposare
perché un re si deve sposare e deve fare degli eredi
ma bianca di castiglia
non andava ad accordo con la nuora
e faceva di tutto per tenerla
lontana dal marito
sono cose che raccontano giù in villa sempre
cose che lui ha visto e che lui non sembra
non riuscivano mai a stare insieme
perché arriva sempre alla sua cera
il posto dove gli piaceva di più vivere
in quel momento quando erano giovane
appena sposati
era il castello di pontuaz
perché al castello di pontuaz la camera del re
sta a un piano
la camera della regina al piano di sotto
e c'è una scaletta che le collega
e quindi grazie a questa scaletta
il re e la regina quando erano a pontuaz
potevano stare insieme
ma tenevano tutti e due
degli usceri ciascuno nella sua camera
davanti alla porta
in modo che se per caso arrivava
alla regina madre bianca
gli usceri subito battevano sulla porta
e il re e la regina tornavano ciascuno nella sua camera
perché se la suozia
vi sorprendeva insieme succedeva una scenata
cosa succede a un certo punto
durante la crociata
arriva dalla Francia
la notizia che bianca di castiglia
è morta
e juenville è colpito dalle reazioni
del re e della regina
il re
juenville non l'ha mai visto così
sconvolto come quella volta
gli è arrivata la notizia che è morta la mamma
il re adulto
ma è sconvolto, piange, gli va in contro
gli fa siniscalco, perduto mia madre
non l'ho mai visto in quello stato
poi juenville va a trovare la regina
e anche la regina piange
e siccome questa è un'epoca
in cui appunto i comportamenti erano spesso spontanei
in cui spesso non ci si censurava
si dicevano le cose come stanno
c'era meno ipocrisia formale
juenville vedendo la regina che piangere
dice ma cosa c'è da piangere
ma se era la donna che odiavate di più al mondo
la sua cera che è morta
e infatti la regina dice
ma non piango mica per lei
piango perché vedo che il re è sconvolto
e ho paura che succede qualcosa di brutto
perché lo vedo proprio male, non ho anche a me
non mi importa niente che è morta la sua cera
e gente
appunto
spesso spontanea
di una spontaneità che a noi potrebbe anche
sembrare quasi infantile certe volte
forse sapete
forse non sapete che nel medioevo gli adulti
giocano
giocano moltissimo
in parte sono gli stessi giochi che facciamo a noi
giocano scacchi, giocano ad ama, giocano a baggammon
giocano sempre a soldi va detto
anche a scacchi giocano a soldi perché è più divertente
giocano moltissimo da zardo, ad adi
anche se il re non tollerà naturalmente
quindi
e poi giocano a giochi che noi oggi non facciamo più
noi adulti
cavaliere ed ame se si trovano insieme e si annoiano
possono giocare a moscaceca
possono giocare a nascondino
e nessuno si stupisce silenti
e nessuno si stupisce scripti perché ci si diverte
e gli adulti non si divergogna a divertirsi
non si divertirsi come bambini
durante la crociata
quando uno pensa che avessero cose più serie
faccia bebe bello
io e i miei cavaliere pranzavamo davanti alla tenda
si mette la tavolo la tovaglia bianca
nessun cavaliere pranzerebbe mai sente una tovaglia bianca di bucato
e un altro simbolo di status
i nostri cristalli, i nostri calici pranzavamo lì
nella tenda accanto c'era il conted
il conted era un tipo molto ingenioso
pranzava lui fuori al tavolo con i suoi cavaliere
aveva fabricato una piccola catapulta
e con questa piccola catapulta
dal suo tavolo tirava delle pietre
verso il nostro
e ci fracassava i bicchieri
e Joemil racconta questa cosa
è stasiato
quant'era simpatico il conted
voi immaginatevi oggi
i giochi che si fanno oggi
nei palazzi del potere
ehm
dopodiché
qui chiudiamo perché abbiamo fatto quasi mezzanotte
mi sembra che sia arrivata l'ora in cui
ormai il nostro cocchio si ritrasforma in zucca
e dunque
c'è questa cultura cavalleresca
che non tutti sanno applicare
bisogna essere ben educati ma non tutti ci riescono
però bisogna far vedere che sia diversi dai villani
si hanno tanti privilegi
ma è giusto avere tanti privilegi
perché noi c'è più coraggiosi degli altri
e rischiamo la pelle più degli altri
certe volte si esagera
la crociata è andata a finire così male
anche perché
durante il grande attacco che era stato deciso
contro i saraceni
ehm
il gruppo dei cavallieri templari doveva avere l'avanguardia
perché spetta per regola
interasanta che i templari
hanno l'avanguardia, sono i primi ad attaccare
che è il posto d'onore
ma il fratello del re
Roberto d'Artois, il Conte d'Artois
che aveva intorno a sé alcuni consiglieri
come dire un po' tracotanti
a un certo punto l'hanno visto
che cominciava a accelerare
e sorpassava i templari con il suo gruppo di cavallieri
rompendo l'ordine che era stato prestabilito
a quel punto i templari
vedono che il Conte d'Artois sta sorpassando
e cominciano a spronare anche loro
perché guai a rimanere in dietro
non si può
e tutti gli altri dietro accelerano anche loro
e l'intero attacco che era stato programmato
come una successione di interventi
di vari gruppi di cavallieri
degenera in una corsa
sfrenata perché nessuno
vuole avere la vergogna di essere quello che resta dietro
e va a finire malissimo
i turchi li circondano
il Conte d'Artois viene ucciso
quasi tutti i templari vengono uccisi
la crociata è persa
dunque a volte la tracotanza cavalleresca
provoca anche grossi guai
ma non sono tutti così tracotanti
nella loro cultura c'è un conflitto eterno
fra il culto dell'onore
del farsi vedere del bel gesto
e la professionalità
del militare che sa come vanno le cose
e sa che la guerra bisogna saperla fare bene
il culto dell'onore può servire anche
a farla bene la guerra, ti tiene su
ti dà coraggio
nei momenti pericolosi
a un certo punto
durante questo grande disastro
i cristiani stanno scappando
si stanno ritirando, si cerca di mantenere un po' di ordine
c'è un ponticello
che bisogna difendere a tutti i costi
Joanville si trova da solo
a difendere a questo ponticello
insieme con un altro gran signore
il Conte di Suasson
ci sono solo loro due
si può capitare anche questo in una guerra medievale
che due grand signori hanno perso di vista
tutti i loro cavalieri, loro domestici
ci sono solo loro due a difendere a questo ponticello
dietro i cristiani che si ritirano
davanti arrivano i turchi
due cavalieri montati bene
con delle belle armature, sono dei grand signori
hanno ottimi cavalli spade ben affilate
ecco, due cavalieri possono essere già capaci
per qualche minuto di fermare
tutti gli altri che arrivano
ma chi è che si fa sotto per primo
i saraceni si fermano
e cominciano a urlare
a digregnare i denti, a gridare insulti
a tirargli pietre
cominci a sibilare qualche freccia
e a questo punto
Joanville e il Conte di Suasson
si dicono sì, bene adesso la abbiamo fermati
che facciamo esattamente adesso
quelli
sono lì che urlano, ma appena si muovono
e dice Joanville
il buon Conte di Suasson
mi prendeva in giro
perché avevo paura
e mi diceva siniscalco
lasciamo la strillare questa canaglia
perché
per la cuffia di Dio
perché lui giurava così dice Joanville
fra parentesi
per la cuffia di Dio
ne parleremo ancora fra voi e me
di questa giornata
nelle camere delle dame
e questo è uno di quei casi
in cui appunto la cultura cavalleresca
dell'onore dell'orgoglio
per il mese del vantarsi
ma il vantarsi lo può aver vinto non lo può aver perso
vinceremo, torneremo vivi
e di questa giornata ce ne ricorderemo
e nelle camere delle dame
faremo i belli a raccontare
le nostre avventure
e Joanville è vissuto così a lungo
che insomma c'è arrivato a raccontare le sue avventure
e un pochino ho provato a raccontare vele anch'io
grazie